hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
pseudogenes so let's go ahead and get
started first what our pseudogenes
pseudogenes our former genes that have
accumulated mutations and this is
important because they've accumulated
enough mutations which alter the the
nucleotide sequence that alter the gene
enough that those mutations make these
genes non-functional so genes in the
genome of an organism that are so
mutated that they are no longer
functional they're sometimes called
vestigial genes vestigial what this
means is that they have lost their
function in the course of evolution the
idea here is that these pseudo genes are
descendants of genes that were
functional in ancestral organisms so
long ago in the distant past these were
functional genes that carry out
important functions for the organism but
over time over many many generations
they picked up mutations and eventually
became non-functional and so you can
think of these pseudo genes or vestigial
genes as being remnants of once
functional genes now let's talk about
the mechanisms of origin basically how
do these pseudo genes come into
existence and there's basically three
different mechanisms that we know of one
is that it might be gene whose product
is no longer needed for survival so the
idea here is that it was a gene that was
once important than an organism but over
time as the organisms environment change
changes as the population of these
organisms adapt
and encounter different things there are
certain genes whose product remember
that the product of a gene is a protein
usually and so those proteins are simply
no longer needed for survival and what's
a good example of this there is a
bacterium known as Mycobacterium leprae
or I'm going to abbreviate it M leprae
and this is actually the bacterium that
causes leprosy and it's a great example
of this because it has over a thousand
of these pseudo genes in its genome
that's approximately 50% of this
bacterium genes there are non-functional
that are so mutated they don't work
anymore they're not being expressed
anymore and how how can this bacterium
even survive that well it turns out that
Mycobacterium leprae is this obligate
intracellular bacterium it survives and
replicates within human cells where it
uses human cell products so it uses
enzymes and and others were materials
and metabolic processes that are present
inside the cell so it no longer needs to
make those proteins by itself and so the
genes that originally coded for
functional products in a fargus an
ancestor of microbes bacteria block ray
these are needed anymore and because
they are needed they have accumulated
mutations and the bacteria just went on
without them and so that's a good
example of that one where a gene product
is just no longer needed another
mechanism is when a gene is duplicated
so this is when you have a gene and
things in the genome and it gets
duplicated so now you have two companies
and one of those copies the original are
really either one remains unmutated and
that's functional and as long as you've
got one that is remaining unmutated and
functional the other one the duplicated
one it's free to accumulate mutations
and to be non-functional without harming
the organisms chance of survival and so
you have this duplicated gene where the
original remains unused
functional the duplicated gene becomes a
pseudogene over time great example of
this is hemoglobin so hemoglobin is the
protein it's got four subunits in red
blood cells that carries oxygen from the
lungs to the tissues and it carries
carbon dioxide and the tissues back to
the lungs very important protein and it
is made up of four subunits two alpha
subunits so one of those is a
duplication or the other and two bigger
subunits with one big and duplication of
the other and those are all functional
but there are additional duplications
beyond those first implications so there
are I believe it is five more
duplications and those five additional
duplications they're just not needed it
doesn't matter if they pick up mutations
and become non-functional because the
other alpha and beta genes are fine and
are functional and are working in a body
and so those duplicated ones can pick up
these mutations one of them is still
being expressed the others are so
mutated that they're not being expressed
at all but that's a great example of
this additional mechanism through which
pseudogenes can arise the final
mechanism is what we know as a processed
seojin a processed pseudo gene is a
result of a DNA copy of mRNA being
inserted into a gym so remember that
through the normal course of genetic
information flow in a cell you have DNA
in use as a template to make mRNA well
sometimes you can have a situation where
the mRNA is used as a template and the
DNA is a copy of the mRNA that's called
reverse transcription so when you have
reverse transcription and you make this
DNA copy and that DNA copy then gets
integrated back into the genome that
process is called electro transposition
an example of retro transposition that
adds this non-functional DNA copy of
mRNA back into the genome our pseudo
genes for both actin actin remember is a
protein subunit that makes up
microfilament or they're an important
part of the cellular cytoskeleton and
also ferritin ferritin is an iron
binding protein ferritin binds iron to
store it inside an organism so that it
can be released as it's needed and so
both of these genes for actin imperative
at some point in the human history were
made copies of mRNA were made and then
some of those copies of mRNA were copied
back into DNA that DNA was put back into
the genome and we have these
non-functional pseudogenes of active
Meriton hanging around in our genetic
code now before we leave I want to point
out an important caveat and that has to
do with this word right here
non-functional for a long time it was
assumed that all pseudogenes
all of these genes that were former
genes that had accumulated these new
patients that they were non-functional
and in many cases that's true but
scientists are beginning to understand
that some pseudo genes do appear to have
some regulatory function they might be
able to regulate how other genes are
being expressed
in the genome in a mechanism similar to
something called s I RNA if you are
interested in learning some more about
some of these topics I have some other
videos that might interest you one is
over regulatory RNAs where we discuss
the mechanism of Si RNA in more detail
so if you're interested in that check
out that video on regulatory RNAs
another one that you might look at is my
video on the central dogma which we'll
go over this idea that DNA is
it's RNA and then protein is made and
you can see how this these processed
pseudogenes are an exception to that
rule and that is it for today so thanks
for watching biology professor and I
hope to see you next time bye